this video is sponsored by liquid IV more on
them after the reaction [Music] people what is
going on there citizens of the reject Nation we
are going to watch a movie that is not a horror
movie even though I'm joined by scream Queen Roxy
scri over here it's a horror movie for me because
even though I haven't seen a trailer I don't know
what this movie is about everyone has told me who
I've said I I might do a reaction to it has been
like good luck editing that you're going to have
to blur it I have no idea what we're walking
into right now I I don't really know either
I hear that there's some some action going on
but could be some action or some AC I don't I
don't know what what are we watching hey leave a
like on this video subscribe click that Bell what
did you think of saltburn is it good thanks to
prepper for uh doing the hard work here and I'll
I'll see what I can do to help out with the Ed
on this one prepper is the hard one here oh okay
I got the raunchiest person on here no no I'm
I'm being I'm being koi I'm beating around the
bush uhhuh if we can keep that kind of level of
Comedy up we might be able to get ad suitability
perfectly fine here but full link through watch 3
with your own copy of saltburn is available for a
super sexy rejects over our patreon page thank
you to all have been joining us and over there
John and I cover several things exclusive with
highlights and watch alongs included last thing
I'll say is uh I watched always Lola I had a big
talk with Roxy about it uh just before filming I
have a hard time uh seeing past a friend whenever
they are performing I've just seen the character
I had several people tell me who had seen it
like she's actually really great in it and I
can affirm for you guys I told her about a couple
of scenes that I was actually moved to Tears by so
yeah and then he tried to kick me off the channel
yeah then I said I said you shouldn't be here you
should pursue your career good luck darling
be on your Merry way I really appreciate it it
feels weird to say that during salt burn you know
I expected a burn from you but I guess no salt in
the Ws dramatic and I'm like oh I better be more
soft and sensitive to her now no it was really
nice this is maybe the most controversial movie of
last year right Herald fennel is a
goddess I love promising young woman
and I love her oh my God those are bar
Keegan's lips I wasn't in love with him
but I wasn't I loved him of course did you
watch euph Foria yeah he's great in it and
that was part of the problem he looks like
Daniel De le loved him yeah Jacob all Lord
is a stud and exhausted him people just
wouldn't leave him alone especially the
girls it was embarrassing really how everyone
fed over him this feels like out of a different
era this must be an obsession film that's
why he liked me so much I protected him I
was honest with him I understood him oh God I
loved him I loved him what's the movie with the
peach call me by your name yeah it's given
call me by your name but was I in love with
him okay what are we looking at oh
damn okay oh so it's like
an intentionally supposed to
feel like out of a different era
especially with the uh the frame
[Music] Dimensions it's like call me by your
name me Talented Mr Ripley oh Roseman Pike's
in this she's great as well richardy
Grant shut up these are great actors
Carrie Mulligan oh she's amazing good
job Carmel Roxy and I will give extra
commentary today to make sure there's
something to show in this YouTube video
ahuh it is weird the the like glitching
of it of the text yeah or it feels like
old film a kind of both yeah feels like film
re yeah wonder what the choices for that what
are we in Oxford like what's the deal wow
Emerald fennel produced it too what a stud
have control over the film Margot Robbie
co-producer in one of her movies huh and
she's having a killer year the where's the
runchy stuff hey cool jacket and then they
bone my
husband okay class of 2006 so now we know when we
are no wonder it looks like a
1970s movie it all makes sense
now juicy W 2006 juicy was still hot maybe
in the UK not here in America and he was he's
wearing Ralph Lauren all right Jacob Lori you
say Lauren Ralph Lauren it's not Lauren let's
talk about that for the next 30 minutes just to
fill the time Ralph Lauren Ralph Lauren yeah it
is Ralph Lauren wow this looks like Hogwarts
it does sure every American thinks that when
they see this where's the sworting Hat 10
points for Gryffindor we should have seen
this in the theater drunk that would have been
fun wi Guardian [Laughter] Lio I'm Michael Gaby
Oliver Oliver Oliver quick so you're a Norman
no mates too then Oliver quick what are you
reading uh I'm reading maaps I'm a genius
a modest genius ask me some n you're okay
come on it's it's not like I I don't believe
please come on no I believe ask me then you
chose the wrong table was he assigned here 423
* 78 32994 how would he know if it's real or
not did you come from Far From Home Prescott
yeah whereb you know where Prescott is next
to Estonia it's called back to another video so
how did you get on with the summer reading list
uh yeah okay I think I've read it all love how
in disarray all this is the whole set any idea
where he's got to he's 20 minutes late now
right well I suppose we better make a start
then I'm so sorry sorry I'm late it's the guy who
picked on him he didn't pick on him he liked his
shirt Farley start I take it you're not
a relation of uh Frederica start by any
chance she's my mother I knew her when I was
your age when we were both here freder Ken
before she went to America she's going to be
thrilled that I've being toed by one of her
friends oh no not uh friend Boop admirer yeah
from afar oh not sure we ever spoke these are
my obsessions it's confessions but you get it
oh I get it okay shall we start whoa whoa was
that seductive is that the sexual content are
we free by Browning's last tches to look as
if it were alive oh I love him very good there's
something about him yeah lot of food for thought
there intriguing I told you a lot of this food
for thought so you're picking apart the style
my I say instead of the substance that's kind
of kind of what lazy it's completely valid to
debate the rhetoric of an argument it's not
what you argue but how great Point very true
very true especially if you haven't actually
read the poems look forward to hearing your
essay oh we thought this guy was just a meek
boy but he is not no I feel like we're getting
like a werewolf story like a dude is just like's
going to build into some monster by the [Music]
end he's the outcast in this group did you
know there was a college Christmas party
tonight NFI me and you not invited you get an
invite in your pigeon Hall I haven't checked I
have he didn't ohing ERS like we wanted to go
anyway as if we actually want to talk to those
vapid I love the like morbid
comedy here o good song Let's
go so a deals with like desire daning
Christian yeah desire were you desire Obsession
and classism all the things you're great it you
all right um yeah I've got a flat tire he's
in his actual voice look I'm not really going
anywhere just give your bike taking these back to
the library taking my bike I it looks like rain
I wouldn't I wouldn't want honestly it's no big
deal you're my college so am I yeah not noticed a
are you sure I mean it's a bit of a FF willing
get back to college you want me to take yours
back oh no no no I just I'm sorry I just thought I
thought I mean I can with it back to college it's
it's not a dude I'm Felix Oliver Oliver Oliver I
love you I love so Jacob all Lordi likes to play
people who are lusted after yeah but in Euphoria
he's like a known dbag yeah here it's like a
subtle Jameson spends the whole time staring at
it completely ignoring the fact she can barely do
a Time's table not exactly does in company going
for a slush get me another pip please Oliver man
this this guy's just pushed around where's
your agency Oliver oh there he is Ol Oliver
Oliver are you talking to me me this Oliver
hi mate all right this is my hero right here
I was just telling everyone how you save
M oh he's right next to him see I owe
you a drink here show up yeah I'm sorry
you with friend uh no they're just left
dude it so it begins talk about a burn huh but
if I was a friend I would walk over and be like
what I'm in what are we doing tequila
I feel like England's not a teila
place what was
it bombs hey it's your round man I should go
to bed no you can't snake your way out of a
ground I'm not it looks like you are there's
this great sense of like percolating anxiety
underneath the surface of all of this just cut
him and break me what and that round's going
to cost a fortune [__] looks actually
a Lord's Australian he's doing a British
accent here okay yeah yeah yeah could I
just pay in tomorrow sorry mate you're
not even close please thought you might
need a hand with these ones mate when you
drop this a way to protect him I was going
to Nick it but I thought I'd do the right
thing that's sweet pay back tomorrow you feel
like there's chemistry yeah yeah I kind of do
too see it comes to debauchery
he looks more and more handsome
yeah I don't know what it is about
him it's the talent he's so effing
talented and that's that's hot yes
little smile my little talented kid
it is nice to see Felix kind of take Oliver
under his wing after Oliver did do that thing
for him at least he didn't just blow him off
goes against cliches too F's mom m ran away
to America when she was 19 to escape the cold
hearted English yeah s ah don't smoke yeah he
will now she had up the wall and a fat chunk
of dad's money too until he had to finally
cut her off he decided he would pay for all
of far's education he's been expelled from
almost every school in England foring off the
teachers can't do that what do they teach you
Latin water polo and abuse oh do you have any
siblings what do your parents like siblings
no this is very well written and uh my parents
I don't see them that much why just uh they've
got problems what problems mental health and
addiction and stuff dad was kind of dealing
and stuff dealing really was it was it awful
these are great scam work man he's so could
play the prince I don't know which Prince but
not Prince do these guys do actual school work
does anybody in college mey mo catch a tiger
by his toe if he's let him go you're out boy
SC there is a palpable sexual tension between
them oliv quick you look different do I he'll
get bored of you boot liquor rude but not
untrue it's tough being a follower when
you don't really have your own self
identity I'm I'm sorry Felix but no
one wants to sit next to Oliver not oh
my God God he's a scholarship boy who
buys his clothes from oxan harsh that's
so harsh you're such a s sorry oh great
silhouette he's just trying to be
cooler oh my God is he in the room oh this is
from earlier when he was watching creepy this
is a rather sensory experience yeah Emerald
fennel is like a very 360 director from all
angles all touches I feel yeah there's like
this like consistent unease I'm feeling so
hot cool shot I'm cleaning up only rich people
can afford to be this filthy I never do it yes
I will no you won't yes I will I said I'd do
it later Ollie stop I'm not a child I can do
it myself a should I be caring about Oliver
I feel like he's going to do some dangerous
[__] uh I've got some revising to do I think
I might U I might catch you later yeah so it
begins it's not fair to be Jacob ay being
like that like tall goodlooking why is it
that I would choose Barry 10 out of 10 times I
mean he's more break to everyone ja is really
good though is really good yeah but Barry Oh
my God like every he's giving it every pore has
like I mean this like this this character already
feels so multi- later like he's like sheepish and
shy right now but you can feel a darkness
that can overcome and overpower a situation
building yeah completely I also think they're
killing the music in this it's very 2006 yeah
but when they were in the room the music was so
quiet and that they just they understand how to
do it I was just sing a fedix was in uhoh we
supposed to meet yeah they're all at the Pol
oh okay is he going to do it with her he didn't
say Sorry God whatever do you have any alcohol I
thought you like me to have I thought Oliver
was repulsive he said would you like me to
have alcohol a good for them is it no no it is a
terrible situation but good for Oliver I mean he's
think he'll be that's why she's doing it yeah
I don't think I'll even register wrong choice
wordss you forgot the purpose of why she
was there oh and he's rejected that's gross
meanwhile he's cleaned up Jac's apartment
but can't clean up his own vomit what's
happened his dad died how' that happen cracked
his head on the pavement a probably drunk there's
some amazing symmetry to the shots man yeah is
your mom all right she was completely incoherent
they're going to have to let you skip exams and
you're in no state to do them now I me you've
got to go I'm not like you Phoenix this is all
I have scholarship right he's thrown his whole
identity into this oh nice Tu thank you it's a
rent right always check the sleeves but still
not bad I mean you're almost passing I hate him
God always taking a chance to take a jab come
on them follow me wait wait wait where where we
going some people just are like magic and Felix
is like magic he's got that magnetism everybody
wants to be around him very few of us do and I
know what it's like to be that guy you know what
I mean you can affirm this yes yeah thank you for
sure we have this tradition right when somebody
dies we write their name on a stone and we Chuck
it in the river my great-grandfather started
it when his son died in the war I've only done
it for my dog so far but there's nothing worse
than when people compare having a dead dog to
having a dead parent does that happen to you all
the time of course so annoying I know he wasn't
comparing but that happens nonstop DPC rise
up we should have a DPC Twitter I know what
it feels like cuz my dog's dead so what do I
do don't know really um I guess we could say
a few words or I mean we could just stand here in
silence for a bit and then you just just Chuck it
in it's nice though that he's doing something
for his friend trying to support him I feel
like it also he does it out of some type of way to
make himself feel better or something about Felix
that there's a hint of disingenuous and to keep
him around well that can't be good oh he hit the
rock
well why don't you come home with me come to Soul
oh that's the title of the movie I don't feel
weird I don't feel weird I mean my ni people come
to stay for months at a time and you know what if
you get sick of us you can leave I promise is he
a real friend I don't know I think he thinks he
[Music]
is damn we watch a lot of movies where
people are so rich I know well I don't
want to see poor people on screen he doesn't
like it when people say poor that would be
depressing cuz it's like looking at friends
gosh Mr Quick you're early got the earlier
train well do let us know next time you see
the gates were not open that's that's okay
we sent someone to pick you up just the
the distance he's so much above him yeah
I love how uh Oscars constantly in like in
certain scenes yeah certain scenes they keep
Oscars specifically in the in the shadows
except the fact that his name is Oliver
yes cuz who's Oscar you're right you're right
red staircase I accidentally my cousin here what
I think we heard it right we should have watched
this subtitles Green Room Garden some hideous ruin
what an amazing track broken piano and the music
this is the long Gallery uh dead re dead relies
for Daddy's old Teddy acting so good in this
bathroom oh by the way we're going to be sharing a
bathroom I hope you don't mind otherwise you'd be
miles away on the other end of the house oh what's
that going to lead to stuff stuff with them mom
has a F of beards and stubble so I left a razor
for you in the bathroom she thinks it's unhygienic
anything else I should know about no no just be
yourself other than just no stubbles on your
face M's never existed that's a made okay let's
go they probably don't have rehab in Liverpool
no gosh or R and Pike is his mom remember me
saying that at the top I didn't know it was his
mom though Darling where's Liverpool uh North
North yes oh that's Carrie Mulligan M was the star
of promising young woman so she must have a good
relationship with traumatized oh they come out
drunk is that right that he had to put his down
his mother's throat to make her sick that's
private stuff dude why is guy always walking
at the wrong time and conversation cuz he walks
in quietly when you're poor that s of thing does
happen a little bit more Wonder oh the black sheep
of the family parents are Tru addicts I actually
understand and here he is now we were just talking
about you don't be ser really Mary oh my God he's
keeping it on his upper hello Oliver darling
Oh what beautiful eyes oh how wonderful yeah
I told you it you see oh but darling you're kind
about everyone you can't be trusted what a great
line has venisha seen you yet oh my God she'll
die she's been draping herself all around the
house all day hoping you'll come across her as it
were do stop poor boys only just arrived oliv what
a great shot to capture the awkwardness of this
totally this is my dear friend Pamela who's been
staying with us hey Pamela doing what are you go
and find Annie and ask about tea which one's that
you'll find it D an I would love to meet a family
like this though the latest one is some ghastly
Russian billionaire malignantly ugly of course and
she's been held up here for months hiding from him
let's not talk about that this is so awkward yeah
but she's killing it right now just the social
anxiety is so strong dress for dinner yeah it's
like it's like black tie could have brought one oh
no don't be silly I mean have a spare it would be
a waste will he fit into yours that's right we'll
get it sorted I'll uh I'll get you some I'm really
happy you're here every shot is perfect I don't
know if I mean overly complimentary but I get
like old school Hitchcock Vibes here just because
of how the build has been so well to like you
just know something it's just going weird going
to be crazier I don't know what I'd do without
elizeth she really saved me don't bang on about
it P darling you know we're delighted to have you
for however long it is you mean to stay forever oh
no I I think I'm out of um found somewhere oh well
done [Music] darling I love living in a bedset in
my 20s it's so freeing to live all in one room and
much less cleaning to do oh it be terrible When
You're Gone how will I cope I could actually stay
for a little bit longer no darling do and her blue
dress is so freaking fabulous it hurts that is so
aggressive yeah what she did I'm interested to see
how this movie progresses where you see like how
Felix is similar to his parents it's nearly full
you know that means we're all about to lose our
minds is that what that sorry you must be you
must be cold wow he just ran out there in his box
like hi see wife likes you so much you're so um
real of all the words it was the perfect one
even more than last year's one last year's one
last year's one look I just feel like there's
some stuff we could put in the YouTube video
so we're in the clear from here on out it's
all going to be blurred how would you like
your eggs oh it's f i i can get them not the
eggs the eggs are made for you and everything
else is on the side SC what's weird when like
the the servant is uh judgmental fried over a
please shelle's housekeeper was cleaning
one of the rooms when Shelly walked past
the window and waved at her she waved back
before she realized that Shel was in Italy
and she was on the top FL the house oh stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop I won't
hours lat he drowned oh that's just giving
me bumps I heard he his sister oh for God's
sake yes of course you did was gly did he is
not what he asked for no bread to go with that
is everything okay o uh of course yeah it's
just um runny eggs I I get a bit sick from
them oh my
God we're over here Olly is she
naked I can't tell hi mate hey
oh this must be some like dream he's having let's
go is this real feels like
a dream including MGMT I'm
obsessed out yeah let's have some fun before
we mess things up thistles everywhere see it's
got a real white butt doesn't see the sun
too often it's very real I guess that was
real oh my God the ring he's going to bang this
whole family isn't he we go from super bad to the
ring oh my God realistic way of getting Disturbed
whoa what a hell of a shot sick what a fun
vacation oh he wants to be that popsicle I
take the opportunity the paly plates do you
mean Bernard palac the 16th century Hugo ceramist
yes do you know him I've always loved his work but
I've never seen anything of his in real life makes
sense the father would be drawn to him so weird
[Applause] stop this is an awesome
montage cuz we're really feeling
it like all right look at them
really get settled in yeah and
Vibe oh he's just watching him yeah do not get
caught if you get caught oh my God I'm GNA
squeal you know we can't show most of this
YouTube my YouTube I mean reig Nation well
okay so let's describe it for them they' seen
the movie they know what's happening this is
the scene that I You' heard about I have Roxy
did not tell me the scene no I'm just letting
you know I've been oh no we're not there night
mate oh we maybe we are I've been warned about
something that's a phobia of mine and I told
Roxy don't tell me I'd rather just wait to
see oh no I'm so scared Greg I actually
can't oh my God Greg Greg Greg [Applause]
Greg no no no no it's no no oh that is so
funny oh God that is hilarious not the sound oh
my god oh I hate it he ate the paks you know you
know how I feel about liquid germs the oh the tub
no is that what you were told about yes you know
I I have a phobia of liquids the tub liquid he
ate the peach Army Hammer did not eat the peach
he ate the peach what the come here fingers for
pudding I'm sick the drain is so gross I hated
that I love how we always have two different
responses hated that I was lesbian for a while
you know all just too wet for me in the end men
are so lovely and dry oh my God she's so funny
lovely and dry she's so funny cuz cuz what because
you're so beautiful he's going to bang this whole
family or oh no he's like a deviant Rising
what do you think uh Pamela will be wearing
tonight she's gone James thought it would
be better to peel her away this morning
without too much for scen only so many
hints you can drop yeah she did seem a
bit lost oh my God he's had like some kind of
Awakening you think she was a riot to look at
her but there's absolutely nothing going on
underneath if all of it was true her stories
to the angel seemed a bit inconsistent at
times I thought you noticed it too oh yes
I had absolutely the emotional blackmail
I was feeling quite guilty about it this
afternoon but you're absolutely right there
was actually something quite Sinister about her
yes she might be my favorite performance in this
film she's so funny she is amazingly funny she's
so funny Oliver MH um I love watching his
transformation yeah he weaves in and out
of like now he's just like becoming like well
he's probably had to adapt his entire life you
know he's becoming confident you're watching
him be molded yeah look at that just like this
shot of like every shot in this Emerald holy
crap like how he was in the shadows before
but now he's embracing the darkness and he's
above yeah it's called film observations and
you want to be in a see-through night dress
underneath my window wow this is all playing
like a fantasy you're not eating anything yes I
am well you're not keeping it down I mean you're
so beautiful Venicia you need to look after
yourself oh so tomorrow you're going to eat
and then you're going to stay at the table
do you understand that was not what I was
expecting there I think he's going to eat now
oh what was that I could just eat you yeah oh
my God it's going to eat her it's not the right
time of the month is there something you think
I'm worried about but your first time come on
man couldn't care less oh my God it's lucky for
you H oh my God oh my God I used to ask myself
what would ever do every month wow wow he is a
vampire that's a bold move movie so for those
who can't see what's happening on YouTube there's
blood I got to tell you Rox this not my cup of
tea are you kidding this isn't or that isn't I
mean you know either what you know I'm just
like in heaven right now are you I like that
is not my thing right there only because
what's sexy is like it's her body and it
just is what it is and if he doesn't care
it's just I mean roll tide roll respect for
you enjoying it oh no Jacob Lord is watching you
stupid little boy oh no what are we looking at
whoa what was that shot artistic I mean it
was him in the bath with the blood on his
face oh that was real it seemed like like
a what was that art artistic sh I was lost
gr wait who is coming to dinner again the
Henry who the Henry's dad's friends they're
all called Henry little baby by Henry well
I'll put you next to Oliver then he can you
instead what kind of party I don't know whatever
you want about a 100 people 100 or two it's
invariably ends up being two doesn't it with this
sort of thing oh oh how about fancy dress oh yes I
can wear my suit of armor eleth good idea Dary oh
no and he tried to talk to Felix but Felix wasn't
having it and I wonder if the cousin told him or
what's happening what do you think getting with
Phoenicia Ollie what makes you think I got with
Phoenicia Farley saw you too you're my friend
you're supposed to be here with me I didn't want
to embarrass fenicia embarrass he's going to say
she threw him I saw her outside and I went down
to see was she okay and I think she got the wrong
under the stick because she tried to kiss me wow
oh my God he's the villain well why didn't you
tell me I I thought it'd be nicer not to she
was hammered probably doesn't remember she's
so embarrassing you can push him about too I'm
rooting for him yeah he was my best friend at
school and he came to stay with us and he kind
of developed a little thing for venea and I know
everything just got so awkward kind of ruin our
friendship oh it's kind of threatening so smart
because he asked why Felix knew he hooked up with
fisha because if if Felix had seen him he would
have had to Pivot but he knew Felix didn't see
him oh my God she's trying to draw him out right
now y it's interesting cuz Felix's girl was trying
was hooking up with Oliver earlier to try to get
Felix jealous yeah and now Felix seems I don't
know if the right words jealousy but a bit of a
jealousy of like the attention and stuff what I'm
trying to figure out is if Felix has any feelings
for Oliver at all I don't think so you don't think
so no but I be I'd like it though if you think
Oliver has feelings for Felix I mean Oliver th%
has feelings for Felix making me come to you with
a begging Bowl when are you implying why don't
you ask Liam and Joshua who the are Liam and
Joshua your footman that is low Farley Jesus
Christ mate seriously is that is that why you
want to take this I mean we your family we hardly
even noticed that you're different or anything
like that I never know how footman's names could
have used a better choice of words my father has
been more generous than most people would would
be a lot more and maybe maybe we've done all that
we can wow he succeeded or at least oh my God
he is great I I I'm on his side I I want him
to bring it all crumbling to is this the dinner
with the Henry's or is this this the party that
they're talking about theity oh great shot
is it his party birthday party or the Henry's
party well maybe we just need to be a bit more
careful no thanks you're just another one of his
toys I mean he never lik sharing his toys even
the ones he doesn't want to play with anymore
whoa I'm So Into the music what this is wild
[Music] a this is so cringe oh my God all
right this I'm going to get a drink me
too is there's some stuff that Goa his sister
or his cousin it's his sister I thought I don't
know either way it's weird I I I think even
unless when he was saying IED my cousin he
meant Venicia yeah let's make sure to mute
Roxy on finger there guy I didn't know if
finger was a you know but the intention of what
why did you tell Felix about me in Venicia well
I didn't think he react that badly yes you did
yes I did oh my God are is is I did not if you
ever want to talk to anyone you can talk to
me fary what do you mean well going through a
hard time at home I know how that feels things
are so precarious he's the devil un lonely and
it must be so and weird having to ask them
for everything if I can help in any way just
ask clever right I think I'm
going to go put him out of his
misery wow that manipulation he is so good
remember when he said that that other woman
might be lying about her past mhm do you think
it's possible he's lying oh about his family's
mental health and all that stuff that he was
saying no I don't think he's lying about his
past I think it's that past that that making
him do what he's doing yeah I'm your you buy
me things I never want anything it's easy
curreny we spend you pay my rent I love
you you pay my rent W that is mean this is
your song as well fary come finish it oh my
[Music] God cringe cringe
cringe what the [__] are you doing what you
think I'm doing Wedding Crashers I think we're
in the wrong room mind looks like a vase
are you going to behave from now on Farley
no oh my god wow are you going to
B
no is this the right answer to get
what I [Laughter] want I'm going to
pay oh my God I would say the people who said
this was runchy are correct although we're not
always seeing I feel like you for you show is
worse I mean it's outrageous what a cool shot
to say that he'd come by some pacy plate I mean
the idiot he had to have known that dad went to
school with the chairman mom and dad would give
him anything he asked for yeah well obviously
he got sick of asking i' been here yes oh bliss
bliss bliss bliss bliss bliss bliss baby I used
to hang out with them all actually when I was
modeling Brit pop blur oases goth parties but
then of course common people came out and
everybody thought it was written about me
hate common people I mean I barely knew
Javas peasants but she came from Greece
she had a thirst for knowledge it couldn't
have been me I've never wanted to know what
an insanely gorgeous shot God I wish we didn't
have to go to London I didn't know you going to
London Pamela's funeral Pamela died should do
anything for attention she has the best lines
man the delivery she has the absolute best lines
and best delivery it's that one two punch she do
anything for ATT Jesus Christ the N comedy for
her is so great I don't think I'll ever forget
that line this is like an erotic Thriller and uh
it's interesting seeing like the the one who uses
sexuality to overpower being this character like
he's in a very unusual character to be that Vice
for it usually I don't know I kind of Imagine
like hot woman or something like that yeah but
he's so unassuming and just I'm telling you he
I don't know every time I ever brought it up
everybody's like what him for you and I'm like
I don't know what it is there's just something
it is the talent I do know what it is he's just
if you said he can have it but it seems like he
actually loves Felix yeah but he thinks that's
not even on the table it is like calling by have
you seen Talented Mr Ripley it's a little
It's a combination of like those two films
to me morning birthday boy get dressed we're
going on a road trip what I'm a surprise wear
something nice oh my God sugar daddy sugar daddy
wear something nice okay Daddy whatever you want
it's killing me how much further is it it's not
too far now pleas please tell me Felix I look ol
just just hear me out all right just hit me out
oh Prescott you left your phone in the bathroom
so I thought I thought I I sort of just picked up
I mean you've been ignoring your calls for weeks
and I I just thought that maybe I could help oh no
please turn the car around you can't take me now
I'm starting to wonder if the if he lied now I'm
starting to wonder here can you please no I'm not
taking no for an answer mate I'm sorry that that
is very imposing dude yeah that very imposing oh
well this is nice M look she's cly cleaned up
her ass this is lovely SN saltburn oh my God
yeah he might he might have created a whole lie
let me go in without you please I'm not leaving
you mate we're in this together this is one of
the best movies of 2023 for sure I see what the
hype is about this is a great movie if I called
that I'm almost too good it's very much like I
mean you haven't seen the movie but yeah there is
a talent to mrly VI I'm just going to keep saying
it I'm so nervous me too I'm so nervous Oliver
I didn't recognize you happy birthday love you
must be Felix it's so nice to meet you your
father's in the garden his father called it d
oh that was in MOS we go every year oh my God I
fell for his lies not anymore kids are all grown
up did you told me you were an only child all of
it no he's been a massive liar I'm not surprised
if he didn't he always wanted to be an only child
or was beatling off by himself they didn't know
what to do with him at his school he was so
clever that's why I think he found it hard to
make friends oh my God he's a sociopath he's
the top scholar at Oxford the top scholar he
real Li to them God he's so modest you know I
I had no idea it's been hard not seeing it well
there must be a lot of pressure though I expect
oh yeah yeah of course it he knew how to use that
pity to get in I've got these horrible migraines
why don't you like turn upstairs darling I made
you bed in case you got to get back your mother
spent all morning making lunch it does matter of
course we can stay we would love to stay the
resentment did job aori is bomb in this movie
awesome yeah oh [__] if I were jaob I wouldn't
bring him back home with me let me just explain
I think the best thing is that you go home after
your party I will see you back at Oxford and we
can still be friends though I mean we're going
to laugh about they why you're fing liar Ollie
wow where does like the next 40 minutes go this
is so fascinating can you not tell your family
please of course not hell it's dark enough as
it is some people just be Liars I he's like a
path logical liars I'm so upset that I knew he
was lying yeah I even fell for it but it totally
lines up with his character yeah completely does
damn Rock's two in a row you've been acing this oh
my God he's getting worse look at that duality
of it oh that's great that is awesome Duncan
Orchid this movie gets like cooler as it
goes this is a really great movie uhoh
it's George's da uhoh uhoh oh dear and it is
kind of like a horror movie but you know the
one thing that it does ask us to do is like
root for the rich people at some point but
then Oliver ends up being not poor so I don't
know I think there's interesting challenges
the movie poses CU and I think casting Jacob
a Lordi from Euphoria is so smart because it
automatically me I bet he's an [__] but he's
not he's so so like conventionally attractive
yeah and Rich but then you end up finding out
like oh actually I talk to you for one second
you can't ignore me forever I can try Felix
come on man TR ni me somebody else fair oh H
oh that was wild
hello F how did you know it was me Signet
ring God you really do notice everything
yeah this place Oliver's once in a lifetime
hand up on a hay bale golden Big Boy Summer
and you'll cling on to it and comb over
it and you'll wonder how you could ever
get it back but you don't get it back damn
you catch a train to whatever creepy doll
fact creators they make all Oliver is in this
isn't a dream to me it's my house so whatever
happens I always come back interesting
themes of Desire here good monologue and
like how desire can corrupt [Applause] you
nobody knows his name nobody knew his name
oh they're just here to party
I wonder why they specifically placed this
in 2006 like that's a very specific like
time frame I haven't quite seen yet
what what the purpose of it is it's
probably not the same on social media
fair enough yeah but still current day
enough man it's a multifaceted role this
is a one of the best performances of the
Year kind of like it more than klian Murphy
and alimer I'm just going to [Music] say what
are we about to watch they're going into
the Labyrinth yeah I think they're going
to the Labyrinth to go do it and I think uh
I think Allie's going to follow he going to
follow a damn look at that oh my God
these like symbolic like like almost
like mythological hellish shots dresses him for
Halloween for [Music] sure and then come talk to
me easy ticket in with Roxy guys remember the
maze map come on you're smart
observant calculated you can do
it yeah but what's his game plan here just
wants to watch oh and the statue looking
over them wonder what these animals mean Felix
what the are you doing here I need to talk to
you were you spying on us no I wasn't know
you two are Ro you think Felix is going to
kill him I don't think so may be like the the
Hollywood thing to do we need to talk we can't
we can't are you crazy get the away from me look
I just gave you what you wanted everyone puts on
a show for fix so I'm sorry if my performance
wasn't good enough wow the pathos I just need
you to understand how much I you you're the only
friend I ever had Fenix ever hey doesn't this
just prove how much how much of a good friend
I actually am how well I actually know you I'm
still the same person wow the way he can make
you feel sorry for him you make my blood room
cold don't don't Ru this I just think he
plays him so human yeah and I I could see
like such a Hollywood version of this and
this feels like so anti Hollywood I think
you should go to bed interesting it's like
mirroring the stat at you I love the framing
this looks like Zack Snider's Justice League
I was going to just say I bet he gets cast
in a superhero role real quick he was up
for Superman it does make [Music] sense
it's very pretty it is wild that we're not at
our third act yet where it's like what where
yeah that's mean like when that reveal came
like wow we still got a while to go with this
movie uh what happened to Felix
I don't know I was just thinking
that do you think he offed himself would he
I feel like an accident might have occurred
I don't think yeah maybe I think you're right
just wondering earlier with that line about
that oh my God and Felix was the only one who
knew the truth yeah they can't find him yeah
maybe he got lost in the Labyrinth you don't
need to be told do you he ran away away no he
wouldn't run away yeah I just don't want to
admit that he's not here anymore that'd be
crazy you already know you're just turning the
handle on a jacking a box walking towards the
end of the world it's like he always knew he
was always suspicious of him oh they're going
to bring Oliver in like he's their own to like
replace Felix kind of thing oh yeah the ultimate
infiltration plan team Felix I mean no Oscar
Oliver God damn it man what's everyone's name
you good yeah I'm good just so swept up in the
[Music] experience they're going to find him out
here oh no it's the end of everything
I was wondering why he was so swave
there like oh no did he kill him
no I don't think [Music] so but
did he fall like upside down
and he like choked on vomit or
something there was that one
part where you talked about pills
see he fell what is this statue my darling boy
help me move him we need to get him inside get
him warm uh just need to get him warmed
up super in denial about yeah come on now
help me oh no this is sad to watch I think we
can move in J I think I think the police yes
yes come away darling it's nearly lunch yes
gosh the way they like go into denial about
[__] well we were wondering what was going to
happen they're having trouble they keep getting
lost in the Maze Mar say send one of the gardens
to assist fine Oliver darling why don't you tell
us about last night cuz they won't bring it up
yeah it was uh wonderful I think it was a hit
don't you darling and that cake was oh did
you like it what now may I be permitted to
close the curtains the coroner's outside
and may need to pass the window yes thank
you close them I don't normally like chocolate
cake don't look wow last night was so like yes
Lynn has always been an expert with cakes w W
way to keep up this act you have to have cold
hands mhm I oh so but doesn't melt just talk
guys I think that applied more to pastry than
to D just get them clothed for Christ sake the
editing unreal sound design an editing on this
scene I'm so sorry
whoa oh my
God oh my God like everyone confronting
lunch is cold you want me just sit e it
like nothing's happening what else is there to
do darling anything anything sit down and eat
the bloody pie just eat it jeez eat the bloody
pie you wanted to be part of the family you're
not the only person here with feelings none of us
wants your blood American feelings I think it's
delicious wow what I'm saying is I would feel
guilty too guilty if I was the one racking up
lines tonight someone died is that true search
fall is wrong yes no get out oh my God what's
happening el el don't you dare look at her get
out I won't mention this to the police man it's
like being stuck in a sensory deprivation take
of I don't think he killed him but but I don't
know do you think he did he might not remember
if he did the way it was shot made me think no
and makes me I don't know it really could have
been an overdose I don't know yeah I don't think
he would have killed him then again I don't know I
fall for his lies like everyone else oh the teddy
bear see you back at the house Oliver what does
that mean don't come with us he said I'll see you
back at the house right but why not just going
together maybe Oliver looked like he wanted to
spend more time I think as a family they're
doing something to honor him the rock thing
remember yeah yeah I'm just wondering I think
they wanted just to do this alone as a family
yeah in the end Felix was an all right
guy he was definitely the best of
them what are the chances he sleeps with
at the grave yeah man people acted like
this movie was like nonstop you're do
is it that way do something disgusting
and [Music] repulsive oh my God Roxy please
I I actually don't want him [Laughter]
to is he going to I don't know oh no please just
be doing like some bearing your soul
kind of thing okay I think we're safe
the actor had to bear his soul
for this and then they were
playing music oh my God okay I think he's doing it
yeah wow wow this is really happening what does it
say how did you how did you possibly predict that
that is nuts what does it say about me that this
is the only movie I've been able to predict all
the things I can't believe this is so hilarious
what is this like expression of sexuality he's got
is anybody going to see this no okay you people on
screen you know what's happening is he kissing I
he's doing the whole shebang and he's crying this
is a very vulnerable thing Roxy's here like I wish
I was that grave honestly amen I'm sorry soing
in the ch CH at the funeral I felt so sorry for
you and then I remembered and I started laughing I
feel like older I remember then you only knew him
for six months okay you have nothing to do with
him with us with her nothing at all you're just
a stranger it's very light here you are right in
the middle of it all stranger danger danger you
know what Daddy started to call you Spiderman
because you're always just skullking around
weaving your spidery olivery web all fell for the
TR love her I don't think you're a spider I think
you're a snake monster a mo quiet harmless
drawn to shiny things pting up against the
window oh Felix had that same tattoo
you ate him right up and you licked
plate but she's drawn to him
too the way he uses sexuality as
a dominance effect I'm broke her
completely she said it herself she
couldn't live without him who do
oh my God wow he has destroyed
everything and now he's on the
bridge but did he do that I mean it is from
The Chain Reaction or did he literally do it
oh that's what you mean yeah oh no I think she did
it herself but this has to do with her uh with his
actions though man yeah I think it's time Oliver
you to go home discreetly tonight I just think
it's best if I stay just for the time being holds
power over him you won't go I don't see how I
can my man got to respect the game respect the
game every time you say that in these reactions
it's about the worst things possible Greg respect
the game how much for you to leave and never come
back to cease all contact with my wife why
because we all have to move on I know you
live under somewhat difficult circumstances
but it's not even really about the money how
much you think he named it price yeah that's
why it looks all fresh there and uh whatever
that Flash Forward is what do you think the
price was one billion kajillion uh I don't
know the fact that he actually took money
to leave is wild if he did totally won he
said leave in the night so she doesn't
notice but this is daytime no he totally
won prising her role from gong girl she cut her
hair so we know it's been a long time passage of
time he died get back in get back in you think
he's going to try to date her oh that would be the
best Oliver El smart man oh how handsome you
look I can't believe it that you all grown up
it takes advantage of a maternal side too I
read the news about Sir James I'm dreadfully
sorry that's why I'm at this coffee shop that I
know you like to see you cuz I'm a manipulative
Ollie I didn't like it the way James treated
you thought about it a lot and you have to
remember that he wasn't in his right mind
then after everything that happened you
do forgive him you do understand of course have
you been happy not really oh smart you so smart
not really oh my God genius respect the game
Roxy respect the G seeing her outside of the
saltburn palace is so different now you're
catch hering a very see it feels vulnerable
for her come up and stay get Sal H respect
the game for sure oh my God Greg stop saying
that I can in the mirr beautiful shot that been
the happiest of my life who is he talking to
it's just such a shame you got some will oh
knew it but I I I should have said it I was
thinking it damn it so he is he going to get
everything he's going to get everything it's
been a privilege to look after you just as it'll
be a privilege to look after so and you got to
confess it all thank you for trusting me I promise
I'll look after this house just as Felix would
have we got there in the end didn't we no
I think he physically must have killed the
other once thank God after all those terrible
terrible accidents yeah is there really ever
such thing as an accident oh my God yep
accidents are for people like you for the
rest of us there's work and un like you I
actually know oh my God he is the greatest
villain he noticed oh my god oh he punctured
his tire great villain shut up great villain
our fight club moment let's see how he did
it all I don't have any money he did could
I just pay him tomorrow he had money ultimate
manipulator he sent an email to soube to say
that he'd come by some pacy plates yeah we
know I knew that I've actually just bought
a little flat nearby blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah I wasn't in love with him
I know Ione thought I was I loved him by God I
loved them but sometimes I hated them he's also
envious I hate him oh my God he took the rock
I hate all and you made it so easy spoiled dog
sleeping belly up no natural Predators that's
what I'm talking about man oh he poisoned him he
did kill him my one prediction and he pretended
to make himself wow oh like P push the needle
forward for this for the daughter to do it yeah
it was interesting when he was eating his eggs and
he was like the runny ones make me feel sick
and that's like a rich priv kid thing to say
too would if this set up on
alarm in some way in the [Music]
house genius what a cold cold film love
it we still don't even know exactly why
he is the way he is makes it all the more
unsettling this hemp what a perfect shot perfect
shot you took out the family dude you got the
estate oh reversing the shot this time it's
amazing any time it peaks in a
frame you got to look right just
like oh God if he was walking through
being shown it earlier it was like oh
this is he's going to want it if he
wants it he goes after it what a wild
feeling right now it's like is this a happy
ending I mean just the complete ownership
he has where he can walk like just go
around and naked oh I think is so so
clever it's right we can just adjust the crop
on the reaction so we we don't see the you
know he caught all the Rocks
you sick twisted bastard
the real prize possession sick twisted son of a
[__] respect the game Roxy respect the G all
right reject Nation so today I want to share
something with you that has been a wonderful
addition to my health and fitness journey that
I discovered during the holidays and that is
liquid IV's hydration multiplier I'm down to my
very last packet and I'm freaking out but it's
okay I got more in the mail now a lot of you have
been so kind to notice how I've been working on my
physical health thank you for all the compliments
and one thing I learned is that proper hydration
is absolutely crucial especially post-workout
and pre-filming after post-workout and my wife
actually introduced me to this product which is
perfect because we not only care about quality but
a good tast and quality product so whether it's
after a sweaty workout or just after you know a
good night out you know what I'm saying efficient
hydration and replenishing electrolytes is key you
just feel better and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough another thing I'm always on
the lookout for too is products that have zero
sugar or zero sugar added because that's one
of my main dietary restrictions throughout the
week and they of course got products that fit
that description that also taste good too so
yes thank you so much so liquid IVs hydration
multiplier is in summary is they are a non-GMO
electrolyte drink that delivers hydration into
your bloodstream faster and more efficient than
water alone sometimes drinking a whole gallon
is not always efficient but in fact it can
provide the same hydration as drinking two to
three bottles of water also a big on efficiency
plus it's packed with 11 essential vitamins and
we know vitamins are good for the body it's
vegan soy free gluten- free and dairy free
you can customize the water amount to your taste
again perfect for post night recovery traveling
or just having a big night out you know what I
mean noral so if you want to boost your support
for the channel and boost your hydration game
go to liquid i.com and use promo code Rejects
at checkout that's liquid i.com promo code
Rejects and remember liquid IV it's not a
real IV sure feels like it so stay hydrated stay
healthy and let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024 ladies
and gentlemen if you were listening to this on
Apple or Spotify we just watched saltburn and uh
I'm here with Roxy and uh wow before watching this
I was told that it was going to be a hard moveie
to blur I don't think so actually I feel like we
can get away with some of this it's no we near
as bad as as as it was hyped up to be in terms
of like the cuda's sexual stuff I was like no
it's not I mean Greg it goes there but it's it
is so not that bathroom scene the grave scene
and then the ending scene come on sure I guess
I think I think HBO is worse I think Euphoria is
worse I think Euphoria is worse by a l I think
there's like some gross out stuff but it's you
do watch alongs for Euphoria no but I've seen
all of euphoria I like I'm just saying I think
that's what yeah whoa and this like the stakes
were just so much higher too oh my God that was
really good that movie was excellent I I think
that one of the best movies of 20 undoubtedly some
sometimes he's like hyped up Oscar films feel like
Oscar batty [__] to me and yeah this was a I
thought this was a very transportive wonderful
experience that was genius I think it's a genius
movie it's very genius it doesn't feel pretentious
which is what I was worried it was going to be
because exactly like Rich family poor guy and
then it's just so not that yeah that was really
good they did an amazing job with the casting
and then every single shot they made count and
with those things combined plus the the music to
me was just so fantastic it was just a home run
yeah the snaking in its own tail and the credits
here Ora Boris effect yep um I I I feel like this
would also make an amazing rewatch an amazing re
see what you could pick up on the little seeds
planted throughout because I think who's this
director I don't know who this director is
venel she's really really good her big thing
was promising young woman um which was kind of
like this in terms of a little bit of at the end
um almost like a Revenge movie but not a Revenge
movie I think she's on actually gone on the record
to say she doesn't do Revenge movies but in in
the way that this was like a yeah a gotcha thing
I don't know she's really good I'm not going to I
I'll try my best to sound like I'm smart here and
um you know I might sound a little bit you know
pretentious or at least trying to be as we try
to you're trying to be pretentious I'm try to be
pretentious as I try to put on your pretentious
face let me just uh put this back let me um be a
little pretentious aha good point sir legs crossed
yeah okay what do you got pretentious man
[Music] as we unpack this movie because it
is a thought-provoking film what I love about
it is this is one where I'm sure that's it's
of course open to interpretation of what the
movie is really all about and I I thought as
the movie was playing out that I was going to get
some things about like commentary where they're
talking to me about like if [__] the rich or
whatever that it was going to be one of those
movies and to me what I what I was so impressed
by was that it's it seems like they put character
motivation first and foremost and that is really
the theme of the movie which is like desire and
Obsession and that is the character U of uh of
Oliver is he is nothing but desire and Obsession
to the point where he will lie to The Nail about
anything and believe his own lies and I I found it
such a fascin fting portrayal that you watching
this whole experience through his point of view
as you're unpacking this side of the world that
most of us don't know or can't experience right
and you they throwing you into his perspective
essentially our villains perspective to see like
of course you would desire something like you know
we always talk people always talking [__] about
one percenters but that part that pardon all
of us it's like but it might be a little bit
cool to be a 1er right and I think this movie with
that with the audience of like oh yeah mean Oliver
most of don't really have money don't come from
nothing but man me thrust into this lifestyle and
and but also placing into the uncomfortableness
of being ostracized for being less than at first
before getting indoctrinated into the wealthy
family side I thought was so brilliant because
he is the villain of the story but they don't
set they don't tell you that right away he's
the villain though and it it is almost almost a
breaking bades situation where you're like we're
watching The Monster come into fruition but he
was a monster from the beginning like from the
GetGo he's always been this con artist uh it
was a genius performance brilliant it might
be my favorite um male performer of 2023 that I
have seen I haven't seen them all I haven't seen
like the Paul Giamatti movie um but to me yeah I
think well I think Kelly Murphy is like the front
runner for Oppenheimer and I think I thought
he was absolutely brilliant in that film this
Takes the Cake this is the thing like I like that
little Joker teas we got in in uh the Batman but
this made me go oh man I would love to see this
guy as the Joker more than anything else yeah I
definitely feel you in all of that going back to
something you said a minute ago though what do
you feel is the message of the movie I don't know
if there's a message yeah I know I'm sitting here
trying to like rack my brain about about what this
movie was trying to say um and I don't think it's
about it was kind of a slice of Life film exactly
and I think that that's interesting but I do think
that there is there are many lessons throughout
um number one I I'm always so I'm scared crapless
of people and until you you can't know somebody
that quick like nobody can know anybody that quick
and that is always scary when you see people that
get so close to people with in a couple of months
right a few months and it's like ooh but who
is somebody even you could know somebody for
years and still not even know them so I do think
this is like a how well do you know somebody and
love versus lust situation almost too where it's
like are you being courted by somebody or are your
feelings for that person real I mean friendship
feelings romantic feelings as we're watching this
he's just like a a blue-eyed serpent man like
anybody the mom crushed on him the daughter
crushed on him the cousin crushed on him I even
felt at times that Felix had feelings for him
you know there's moments where I'm like is Felix
into him like he just was he was that ick guy and
when we started the movie I was like Wow Felix
is the ick guy like Felix is the guy everybody
wants to be around but really at the end of the
day it wasn't Felix that everybody was swooning
over it it was Oliver I mean it was both of them
in different ways but like Oliver found a way to
hone in on every person and make them feel seen
that's why he focuses on the daughter's eating
disorder right because he's like nobody is talking
to her about this nobody's noticing it and in this
family you brush things under the rug so I'm going
to make her feel seen and when he says that to her
like tomorrow you're going to be eating and not
going to the bathroom after afterwards to purge
she knows that she's been noticed yeah um and
it's the same thing with the mom but like as
he as everybody's calling him so observant and
he's like well you're so beautiful I'm surprised
to hear that he's just he does such an amazing job
of noticing everybody noticing everything noticing
that the cousin had that ring on that's how he
knew it was him this the scariest thing somebody
could be right the most observant person in the
room just yeah he was able to get to everybody in
a way that other people are not what a snake yeah
is it it's a narcissistic manipulator like to the
to the Max and it is a f it's a fascinating to me
this is and for a film that I don't know what the
aspect ratio is that this film was shot in um
it's not 4x3 I forget what the dimensions are
but for it to kind of hearken back to like a
bit of a 70s flare it does remind me a bit of
like the crazy sociopathic type of characters or
Psychopathic kind of characters from the rise of
like darker Cinema and so to see it portrayed
here and then captured in that light I think is
grandiose in in every fashion and Jacob a Lordi
was excellent he just like a guy everyone here
felt so real and to your point about how he
like makes the manipulations and the tactics
of connection the only one we did not see him
do that with is the dad the only one he failed
at doing that with other than the one part where
you see a a brief moment they connected over the
ashtray or the artist who made the ashtray right
but that's it but nothing about a truly personal
level of who they are as a as a human being and he
manages to do that with everyone often in the form
of sexuality like that's how he would dominate so
maybe because he knew that the dad wouldn't go for
the sexuality and so but but he did with the dad
like in ways where he's like this pie is really
good he knows the dad wants to keep it surface so
around the dad he keeps it surface yeah he plates
so he can take contr but that is actually that's
probably a really great point that you just made
is like the reason why he couldn't dominate is
because he uses sexuality to dominate and and in
ways that are like extreme but I love like this
symbolism behind so much of it of literally just
he calls himself a vampire and he is a vampire
and and and it is like sucking on the blood the
literal fluids of just this ultimate lust and
desire he plays he plays the whole thing like
a vampire and a werewolf just a werewolf in
the sense of you're watching him become the
werewolf by the end and a vampire and the the way
he prays and sucks the life out of the family you
know like the movie what I what I love about it
is like the movie kind of just tells you who he
is pretty early on and you think you're watching
a guy transform from sheepish to confident but
really the sheepishness is just kind of an act
act yeah and and so is just pulling back a layer
is what you're doing with him the entire time like
he is the most fascinating character surrounded by
a bunch of characters who are so elevated by
the other performers um the cinematography I
thought was drop dead gorgeous is this what her
films normally look like uh she I I'm trying to
think I think there was another movie I loved of
hers before promising young woman let me just look
but it was promising young woman looked amazing
too amazing so I think that probably but I think
I liked something El that she did a lot too I'll
let you know in a second um another thing that I
think that the movie did a great job with was the
fact that it he is so untrusting that's why he
calls out the other woman who ends up um killing
herself you know he calls her he's he says maybe
she was lying and it's a note to all of us that
typically the most untrusting people are the
most uh are the least trustworthy people because
they're projecting killing Eve that's what I know
her from oh heard of that movie no no that's a
show um killing Eve was that show with Sandro
and um uh that AMC show it was uh I don't know
anything I don't know why I'm taking all these
killing Eve was that really big show um on AMC
with Sandra o and jod comr jod comr was the one
who kept getting nominated for it maybe Sandra
o did as well but that's where Emerald venel um
I forgot about that that's where she came before
promising young woman and people really liked her
from killing Eve which is actually a show that I
didn't end up watching then she did end up playing
Seven in seven episodes of the crown she played um
Camila so she's an actress as well okay cool she's
and she was mij and Barbie so she has been uh a
writer an actress a producer a director what an
effing Talent what a star this woman is just
like going massive places well this movie is
executed with a level of awareness and precision
that you don't often really get like I I really
love how completely character driven everything
was in spite of like wow look at these beautiful
costumes look at the locations they have shot upon
like you utilizing the salurn estate or whatever
the hell it's called in real life uh absolutely
gorgeous and um the like the the original music
backed with the music tracks that they decided to
use to convey emotion uh was constantly spot on to
represent everything of what someone is feeling
internally like immediately from the jump I was
feeling this sense of unease that was kind of
also with like I've heard like risky things
about this and I'm I'm worried about the edit but
I think we'll be fine actually but the uh the the
the uneased though of like the the anxieties that
this movie produces I thought was so great like
there's there's this sense of like um desire
for sin that casts like a Paul over the entire
film that you feel right away before anything's
even really going down and there's a lot of great
misleading I think too uh like in the hands of
Jacob all Lordi and everyone else like no one
none of them were bad he's the bad one I thought
that was so CL but they are in ways right like
when we do hear the cousin to bring up the point
to Jacob a Lordi and he's like I don't want to
just keep having to ask and not while that's rich
people problems and I I it's not relatable at all
I wish I had somebody Rich that I could go ask
to at the same time it's not like we're watching
the most philanthropic people of all time get
together we're not they're not making this movie
isn't making a commentary like rich people are
actually really good they're saying that rich
people aren't always the worst one in the room
yeah they guess well I don't that's the thing
is like I don't really I'm just so fixated on on
on Oliver and what that level of Desire can do
of of of of greed from the perspective of someone
who doesn't have the thing that you would really
want and what levels you would go through to get
what you want so if anything that's like kind of
the commentary of the desire for greed that I'm
at least Gathering From the film like by the end
when he is dancing naked and standing over like
essentially his Trophies the rocks that he would
go and collect of of the rocks that just belong in
the ocean that he is almost the statues that look
the way he would do these certain poses he looked
like the statue of David honestly yeah the statues
that we looking upon yeah I I thought that was
great like he F he has this like almost God deity
complex that he has about himself of he deserves
more and it's completely dismissive of his family
and I think the way the rich people are portrayed
here is yeah like they got dismissive negligent
um uh pompous they got bad characteristics but
they're not they aren't doing what he's doing
like straight up criminal activities you know he
is an ins Ane liar through and through you know
like he he they are they are rude and evil they're
rude and whatever and but he is a whole new level
of of cunning and I I can't help but respect the
game Roxy I thought the end scene was phenomenal
because right before that when we see him in the
coffee shop with Roseman Pike's character she
says are have you been happy and he says no and
then at the end what's incredible is that usually
these movies try to make a lesson like even when
you get you really want you're not happy mhm like
you think you want it but then you're not that was
the happiest we've ever seen anybody any character
in a movie ever him just dancing naked throughout
the house by himself that is what he wanted that
is what he got and now he is truly happy it's
like Brut it's just like kind of unbelievable
to see where he's like because he's because he is
really like a crazy person you know he's really
truly is narcissist really truly is a nut job he
really truly is wants to be rich and alone and and
uh that's what we see and when he says that he
didn't really love that he wasn't in love with
Felix and in fact he actually sometimes hated him
and hated all of them yeah it's just makes it even
more of a brilliant performance by the character
and a more brilliant performance by the actor oh
he's so good he was great yeah I've never really
been on the Barry kyogen train that everyone else
especially you are on train I feel like I've been
conducting riding you know who really is and who
kind of knows him he's a he's a koi individual
oh I knew you're going to say knows everybody um
this this a carpet situation what does that mean
I feel like they met on a carpet I don't know I
thought there was like some in over there like
car some dirty joke uh no I I have no idea uh
how they actually do know each other but uh CO's
obsessed with him cuz he feels like he represents
his Irish representation or some [__] I mean
he's unbelievable he's really unbelievable he
was best part of eternals too so so good did you
see that yeah know I thought it was really good
I like I think anytime I see him I'm like he's
really good but I've never quite slingshotted to
that I get it now meme that people do from It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia this was the movie
that did it for me like oh my God this guy is a
genius actor yeah he's brilliant but especially to
just see him like in banshees of inin is that it's
called inar inter aarin to see him in that which
is a completely different type of character and
thinking about the versatility of stuff I've seen
him in and then this is the first one I've seen
where he is the leading character uh yeah this
this really uh solidified something for me because
when you're watching it you get it you get why all
these people are falling for him like it makes
sense and on paper you might NE not necessarily
see it but when he's alive he's alive it's just
really crazy you there was one he doesn't do it
by sorry to interrupt it was he he does it in
a way where he listens it's not about how to
present himself it you know he's the antithesis to
um Felix where Felix is all about magnetism of his
Charisma and what he has to offer where what he
does is he knows how to just listen and connect
and and and somehow identify and let someone feel
understood that is his power and using that as a
calculation I think is great because normally this
like erotic like Thriller types of deals are it is
about being the one to be lusted after because of
the presentation and whatever but he just knows
how to do it based off of um connection yeah it's
interesting when we saw him first opening up to
Felix's character he tested the Water by saying
you know my parents are are addicts and um it's
been a tough life and he saw that Felix responded
to that so when he knew he was losing Felix that's
when he made up that his dad died yeah because
he knew that Felix would respond to that and not
push it him away he would bring him in closer
like he did because some people want to hear
about trauma and others don't and uh yeah he he
really did he went in I don't remember the thing
that I was going to say to you before it's okay I
think it was a really bad point or I'd remember it
really yeah probably really really um I
don't is there anything else we forgot to
talk about no I think that's it cast great
check thought off directing great writing
solid um music music great we knocked
about that everything so is I I think
come like is there something we totally
missed uh is there something you didn't
like the if I'm being extremely nitpicky I thought
that the cousin in his monologue I wish that he
had could have gotten a couple more takes it felt
a little forced I liked the monologue a lot but
the performance on when she was in the bathtub
no that's the sister the cousin uh oh yeah um
what monologue what's his name trenty trenty um
when he is saying confronting at the part at the
party exactly yeah uh when I when I said that's a
good monologue I was thinking in my head that's a
good monologue I feel like that actor could have
used a little bit um that's fair more subtlety
in it he he was a really talented guy it felt
like maybe they were rushed behind schedule in
that one scene it's just a theory of mine but
literally if I'm I'm being that nitpicky it's
one scene not the performer in general just that
performance in that scene where I was like I wish
we could just slow it down a little bit there
um but that honestly that's my only I thought
that everything else was like truly I thought
this was close to a perfect movie yeah I even
honestly even the handling of the sexuality is
is something that I thought was really well well
done as Extreme as it is that it might just
be chocked up to shock shock value there are
people who don't know how to truly connect with
themselves uh uh connected people emotionally so
they they convert that into physicality into
sexuality so I think that is the way how they
portray that here was a very fast even at the
graveyard I'm like this makes sense that this
guy would do that you know like he's grieving
he's having a hard time he's he's probably gonna
do it yeah that's why when he said it I was like
you know what I wouldn't write it off like if it
kind of makes sense that the guy might do that
uh it of just to feel the actual Connection in a
in a in the most physical way where you can't
really do it emotionally yeah but it didn't
feel like Emerald chose that for shock value
it felt like that was true to this character
but it's also kind of funny the way they did it
you know so I mean a lot of this did feel like
yeah comedy drama suspense I agree it's a funny
movie it's a funny movie totally and unsettling
the mom character she was hysterical I guess I I
mean I'm trying to like find my nitpick about it
uh yeah I don't gosh you know I don't want to
leave you uh hanging in the dust here I feel
like I got to find a nppi you don't have to just
when you said it honestly that was the one moment
when we were watching I was like just it was not
bad I just wanted something a little more I think
if when looking back that friend at the school um
the girl no the guy the weird guy who with the num
yeah I don't know what that was all I mean other
than to represent that he will be that he will
write off I guess it's now that I'm thinking about
it it's like it's representative of his character
the way he like writes off his family and we
reject and deny them and it's cluing because
it is like cluing you into who his character is
right from the get that he was like Deuces damn
you know what that is actually really smart and
the guy's like you look different yeah and the
way the movie misleads it's like yeah I was trying
to find a criticism like but you know what here's
why it's brilliant actually what they did cuz he's
even warning you you think the movie will go with
One Direction but that's why when I realized like
we I was aware of the Run time and then when I saw
we were only about 80 to 90 minutes in yeah that
was crazy and then Jacob all Lordi found out the
truth I was like wait a minute where's this movie
going yeah but when even at that you were like do
you think he killed him and I was like like right
after that and I was like I don't think so and
then it's like yeah he definitely did once the dad
was dead I did suspect that it was the mom he was
talking to um cuz I was like who else would he be
talking to uh I thought maybe the police because
I think I believe and somebody correct me if I'm
wrong I believe Emerald fennels father is a police
officer which is is had relevancy in um promising
young woman and I and I had read some kind of
interview about her talking something about that
like somebody asked her is that difficult for her
whatever whatever it is cuz obviously it's 2024
so people have their feelings about the cops but
um I thought that they were that was they were
asking that question because I thought it might
be relevant to this movie like maybe he was being
tried or questioned or something but I completely
missed the mark on that and so I couldn't even
think about him talking to Mom because I was
like oh he's talking to cops in a suit that's so
weird why is this maybe it's lawyers instead like
yeah yeah but I was wrong I didn't predict that
out loud so I could have been wrong to myself
and never told you guys that but I I wanted to be
honest with you unlike Barry Keegan what having
Run tomatoes that's the last thing I'll let you
go Roy I would guess it's very high on Rotten
Tomatoes I would guess I would guess low audience
score I would say the critics are probably high I
would probably say this is probably an 807 I
would say mid audience score what beekeeper
has pretty damn good reviews I was not expecting
that okay go find go find this I did not expect
that I really am so surprised oh 71 I thought
it'd be a little higher oh my God the audience
score I way off here too audience score is higher
than the critic score candy coated and incisive
salurn is a debauch jol to the senses that will
be invigorating for most huh sounds like a passive
sounds like Ron Tomatoes sounds like Ron Tomatoes
themselves to say something to me yeah I think
most people enjoy sof is really intense easily
gross out or offended this probably isn't for
you I don't feel like the gross stuff is barely
in the movie I think that that's crazy that you
keep saying that it's barely in it's like it's
like short if you think about a two 2 hour and
11 movie it's probably like 10 minutes of the
movie I don't feel that way at all if you take
the calculation of the time run of those scenes is
barely in the movie I don't feel that way are you
only talking about sexual stuff because yeah
no I mean there's a lot of violence too like
somebody violence think about her in the bathtub
like that's horrific to watch think about him with
the at the end with the mom that's horrific to
watch think about like when they're saying the
easily grossed out stuff you're grossed out by
that by somebody covered in blood in the tub yeah
that was I feel like I've seen in like a billion I
mean yeah it's disturbing yes I'm not going to I'm
not going to write that off as like you know I've
seen [__] I'm a cop or something you know I'm
just saying I saw a spit that just came out of my
mouth I didn't see it but I drew attention to it
out of uncomfortableness lot I think there's a lot
in this that's like whatever people have talked
about it they've said like it's the sexual stuff
that and to me that's where my mind kept going
I'm like that's not that bad what are you looking
for I don't know doesn't matter all righty guys I
got to get Roxy out of here uh what did you guys
think of salt bur what's your interpretation of
it leave your thoughts down below uh Roxy thank
you for driving here and sounds like 90 minutes
of traffic no it's okay it's not your fault brutal
it's not your fault oh is this Goodwill Hunting hm
Goodwill Hunting oh we're doing Goodwill Hunting
they not your fault you got that yeah I got to go
see about a girl you Boston freaks I like that's
your Bible right there at Goodwill I got her
number um and leave your thoughts down below watch
always Lola appreciate you being here see y'all
soon Chris Wham off Chris Chris Wham off my man
it is 2024 and at the end of 2023 this guy this
guy I think to our live streams I think he
contributed like over $2,000 at minimum at
minimum so for 2024 here's what you're going to
do you're going to sue us so you can earn that M
I'm talking small claims court man there's a way
where you can do it you can be like they somehow
hacked my system misappropriated funds by hacking
me you could blame us and then you can earn more
it's actually a wise con that you can totally
pull off cuz it makes no logical sense to give
that much money sure you must be insane yeah like
all I got to do is like why would I do that why
would I give that I'm getting married I have a
hot Filipina fiance why would I possibly give
$2,000 to these random people on the internet
I've never met in person that would be totally
ludic careless of my financial spending habits to
have done such a thing when I'm trying to start
a family right now why would I do that why all
they would do is mock me for giving them $2,000
CH you're a sucker Chris wh off you're a sucker
and we got you no man you've been amazing he's
got a beautiful penoy pry baby you're going to win
it back after Joy Koy destroyed it for all of us
you're going to win it all back man Noy it's okay
and uh I hope you have some beautiful haa babies
it's going to be great man you know keeps keep
you know watering down the this litter of the
Filipina blood that's right you know right white
men stepping in ruining it for us that's what I
am I'm half my dad was the white one oh okay and
my mom was the Filipino one good yeah John didn't
know all for 20 years that's why his response was
like oh okay I didn't know wow inter I couldn't
ever sell fascinating SW your dad was Filipino I
guess that's just be be blind um yeah but no Chris
man I hope that this year you save wisely and that
you're able to have that dream destination wedding
and maybe buy uh buy me a ticket to go to the
Philippines for your wedding John will save up
and I will and I'll fly myself out I'll find my
own hotel I will I will do Babble lessons on on
you know toal it'll be great they're pretty much
bilingual out there John I will not rest upon my
privil g i appropriate myself into probably be
fine honestly then why are we already going to
the Philippines we could we could shoot there and
uh make sure you get me two beds just so that way
I could tell John sorry man I just don't want you
in this room I yeah that is for my luggage that b
is so my luggage doesn't have to touch the floor
that way I don't have to shuffle through a closet
I just don't I just want it right there under this
cover ready at a moment's notice yeah I just and
we're ready to go which is just smart thinking
yeah efficiency that's why Steve Jobs always
wear black shirts that's all I'm going to pack
it's the same shirt of BS i' be like sorry man
he need ready to go any he's got just 100 vacuum
sealed shirts and pants black shirt turtleneck
brown slacks ah buddy well I love you Wham off
and I hope that you're able to uh you know keep
getting uh keep getting your your M Wham off you
know what I mean bam think you m off is that what
you say after you finish the deed Wham off the
Wham off deed wh off off wh off flame on anyway
show her this I'm sure she'd appreciate this more
than you will happy uh New Year [Music] buddy